[Music]
pretend I did it okay cuz I don't worry
I'm sorry I just want to eat it I don't
want to make it what'd you do now
that's incredible look at that yeah this
is the weave all right and it's a big
strip of bacon I mean that's what it is
and you just slam it down like that
alright let's throw mine down even
though it's really not well made at all
but oh alright
and we're good to go that looks like a
crime scene all right and this is uh
okay so that is now cooking away all
right just leave that there you know
cook it low and slow you have to cook
bacon low and slow and people make the
mistake they cook it too quick and then
it gets if you like crispy egg and
that's fine too but if you want to cook
bacon right get thick bacon cook it low
and slow and you drain the fat off the
bacon by any chance know you don't I had
a feeling you don't we do deserve it do
you add fat to the bacon we have fat our
eggs and everything else our bread like
fat seasoning it's really good seasoning
but yeah we do add fat to everything
make it fat to everything okay
we ask you very quickly what this is
right here because you don't just make
while the the tacos are cooking here
what is this right here well this is a
really really rich delicious brownie we
spread Nutella on it and then we drizzle
it with with bacon sprinkles you just
threw bacon on top of a brownie exactly
all your recipes are a regular piece of
food with bacon on it that's it try our
bacon wanking that work it's a woody
cake with bacon on it
that's it so that's fantastic do you
mind if I take a taste to take it okay
oh oh that's like the salty and the
sweet yeah it's sweet and sour all right
so I'm sorry sweet and savory som that
you're either drunk from whiskey or fat
I don't know which one that guys do you
want in on any of this you want some
food come on
[Music]
you're about to have a child that's as
good a time I say do you do eat bacon
aye I do would you like some would you
uh would you like a taste of any of this
right here sure I'll try yeah I'll try
that brownie okay yeah
the that's been the first line of a bad
night yeah
[Applause]
where will you wake up
alright good you like oh yeah Andy what
would you like some bacon yeah these
wings Andy we have hot sauce covered
wings that's bacon hot sauce cover wings
with hot sauce covered chicken wings
with their chicken wings with bacon on
[Applause]
your formula a long time ago
we've been through this so that's
chicken wing with bacon on it and that's
a sandwich with bacon in it that's it
and look what I did I added your bacon I
thought you didn't see that no no but
it's more Bacon's better big all right
are we ready to make the the the death
talk what we do is uh pop some cheese
down like a little potato on top right
and then you know get a little sizzle
going here right what does that you put
on row that was lipitor it's yeah
and then when it's done all you do is
you flip it over
with this here right and then it's gonna
look well it looks delicious yeah I like
that yeah that's great have a nice extra
one here yes oh and then we do that
thing that Martha Stewart what's already
done why don't we just cut to this right
away
that's fantastic who wants to go first
anybody Andy you interested yeah you
don't want you know I will - well then
you go first well you start on one end
then all right that's the most amazing
thing I've ever had no I thank you thank
you that's fantastic and this is all you
can get this at the bacon
[Music]
well that was fantastic Jerry really
wiped my hands
Hey right a guy at a party told me
that's the best way to what grin
[Applause]